keegan-michael key let me raise my voice
okay that's my business I was just you
know I have a perfect you know we were
sitting here we were talking about
awards and there's an award winner today
here because Olivia won an IMDB star
[Applause]
tell me about making predator because
this is a remake and everybody looks and
they say well can you remake an original
something so good something those
beloved yeah it's a reimagining is not
even that it's simply it's just simply
another chapter in the story of the
universe of the predator another just
another piece another rivulet of this
you know main river that we only let her
the Predators you do you just explain
everything now you do it in the
commercials or do it here to you what
was it like making this movie in who is
the predator we have these amazing stunt
guys who get into the I mean they're
really told me to get my music the 610
parkour athletes who carry about 25 to
30 pounds of predator prosthetic
costuming and still they're able to be
incredibly badass in the midst you know
it's funny you mention that because I'm
a little salty with you guys because you
came in dressed in regular clothes last
time Dwight Howard was here oh he came
in a full predator geared full predator
gear he has a put it on in the bathroom
he put it on in a bathroom and he walked
around in full predator gear that's
Christa being any six head so when he
walks around people are like holy cow
that's the predator right right yeah who
knew Dwight Howard was such a predator
fan yeah that's I did not was out of
which of these he went all in good yeah
I'm disappointed in myself okay thank
you
what unites can I go to the mountain for
once can I just say congratulations we
talked about Olivia's war can we talk
about your wedding yes my wife and I
have been married for four weeks now and
we are existing in wedded bliss and we
were really we're just we're really
happy yes yeah you me Lisa just yeah
Alyssa live is living with us waiting is
paintable are you gonna go on this is us
now I mean is that no I would be more
than happy to be on this is what would
the role sterling be for these two I
already know what Olivia's role what is
boys I'm cute you know no we would go
back and we would learn that she somehow
had snuck in and before Jack died there
would have been some kind of like
craziness with Olivia you meanie we've
had an affair yes I don't like that I'm
not a big supporter of you know
portraying that image I just remember to
like I said where the women are always
like you know no Olivia this is
different oh is it because it's
different are you talking about for
Rebecca or you come out in the midst of
the piercing plan with being already
getting a little very when they separate
and step apart and you would meet this
woman yeah who knew
and loved him and it was a part of his
life that you never knew about and the
kids would all freak out when they hear
about it's a Dick Whitman thing okay
Keegan like Keegan I would like to
seeing him be friends with William in
the past and probably someone who helped
him make his transition away from using
I think that would be a really
interesting character and then get to
meet him in present day as his somebody
who knew my father like that would be
cool and like a spiritual component yes
yes I like Lord give you more chances
than you have and a job people think
that kind of like a bag of okay we'll
work on your role okay don't know
whether it's because everybody cries on
it and when I watch these to me I think
I'll just it's just too emotional like
that's honestly what I do I watched one
clip and I was already bawling I don't
think I'd watch the show right now it's
like so devastated you know breaks your
heart I would still like that no I know
is sterling that could you ask him to
stop breaking our hearts cuz it's too
much i watch one click and I'm like
it's okay
still you play top
you play an operative yes yeah tell me
about your role so names will trigger he
runs something called Operation
stargazer he kind of collects data about
extraterrestrial terrestrial yeah but he
specializes in information over the
predator because we know like we follow
the history we honored that the predator
has been here several times in the past
we're trying to collect as much
information as we can to arm ourselves
to learn about the predator to be ready
to fight it the next time coming forth
but he's not necessarily a good guy or a
bad guy but someone with his own agenda
that's kind of sometimes at odds with
the other characters in the play your
scientists evolutionary biologists in my
character was brought in by the CIA to
explain what's going on with this
predator they've they now have a new
predator and they're willing to
understand how it has been upgraded and
what it means how the predator has
evolved thank you
my play my character's name is Coyle
he's known only as Coyle and he is a
member of like Madonna
yeah Coyle he's no he's a member of a
group of misfits broken PTSD soldiers
who have who all are doing group therapy
together to kind of get their lives
together they've lived kind of shattered
lives and they get kind of recruited by
the main character Quinn McKenna who's
played by Boyd Holbrook and we end up
becoming this kind of merry band of
brothers that end up end up pursuing the
predator to kind of free ourselves yeah
people joke today that you know since
Arnold did this movie and then he ran
for office that you too should somehow
look he was making that joke that you
should choose should run for office
anything is possible in these days
anything is possible yeah any thoughts
I'm just
working on our campaign message I'm
thinking that we either it's a the key
is brown old simple brown key 2020 ooh
but then I don't want people to think
I'm running by myself since I am a brown
key and then sterling said I heard him
saying I heard you say on the side of
your mouth for mom you said Keegan go
2020 I'll go 2024
maybe it's premature so I'm gonna go
sterling Kate brown keegan-michael key
on the ticket 2024 let's just one let's
just one but let's just one independent
let's just one independently key K Brown
keeps UK all the way and another person
a center-right Brit oh so it's Jessie
yes I said sunnylands yeah so so there
are three three people who held office
in that first movie that amazing yeah I
mean I get it I think I'm gonna say this
you were just in London right yeah yeah
I just flew in last night and you took a
great picture it's like a kind of
picture like Megan Markel oh yeah it was
kind of cool the Omega mark
she's when she had back in the day when
she was a teenager she went and took a
picture front of Buckingham Palace and
now she's lives there and they were like
let's go see I took my family on a tour
and then some friends is like well why
don't we all just gets it on you know
exactly where she was because maybe
somebody else can marry Prince I feel
like it's the place we're trying to go
I'm going through all the people you
know thoughts and Andrew single now
Andrew who the prints for Andrew I'm
trying to think of you mean like his dad
the older no not the day Andrew the
other good dad age Louie I I want I want
to marry Prince I don't have to give up
my career I want my friends to marry
princess I get although you know yeah I
don't want who wants to give up you up
when you become a whirl you to give up I
mean do you know we found this out you
weren't with us throw same block used to
date
Samantha Markel the really crazy sister
yes he did her back in the day did he
really
yes he was breaking news she's that is
amazing shame block yeah and Samantha
Margolis I mean I think it could why who
doesn't want to make that happen Sharon
okay you know she's real like angry
she's gonna thought agrees and stuff in
the press yeah and she continues to she
continues to her family is working
against her the predator if the predator
were here yeah and he came to earth he
was the one person that you would want
to handle the predator who would you
send after the predator I got an answer
shared this with you before this is a
good Milo Ventimiglia my on-screen
father and dear friend right he carries
like Rambo knives around with him
randomly he's a he's a real alpha man
he's no no dude like one day I was like
Adam up front or something and I had a
tag on a piece of clothing was like yeah
I wish I could cut this tag off cuz here
you gonna stir oh I got he hangs out
like a knife like a street boat straight
bowie knife yes and the straight up Owen
Sheridan I said why why did this knife
is that just in case man just in case
here you go bro
and I was a guess
I need to get out of here cuz
something's something's wrong but my is
that dude he seems all lovey and Jack
but how are things on the set yeah well
my trainers from x-men Ken and green
they are a married couple near martial
arts experts and I learned so much from
them and they're the two most badass
people I know so I send them it getting
gray yeah kind of cream you guys know
Kenan greet you guys pretty much if you
just take anybody from the west side of
my hometown I'm from Detroit it's so
cold and indeed they're gonna be able to
take care of themselves so that's not a
single person Bryson's but I will tell
you well the guys who did our Special
Forces training on predator interpreter
I would I would throw Tom an impact in
there these guys yeah yeah those guys
have stories that I don't want to hear
this a you'd said in your wife and she
[Laughter]
sit down let's talk about things he
wants me to eat are you hungry why are
you so angry with ELISA could she really
could negotiate them he can't negotiate
them back to y'all to a prime fact she
could literally get them to go back to
the brat she would just she would just
negotiate them out of the green screen
because we're have a toast
[Music]